let's bring in sarah palin former vice
presidential candidate and former
governor of alaska
so governor i mean this must tickle you
the irony here is pretty pretty thick
uh any reaction to these 50 migrants
that showed up at obama's vacation pad
yeah and in the meantime arizona texas
others are inviting into their state
hundreds every single day we'll have two
million illegal aliens coming across our
border this year and martha's vineyard
the elites there they're griping about
50. they speak out of both sides of
their mouth of course jesse and it's
just like with gun control they're
trying to take away our arms while their
peeps are all uh you know they're all
firearmed up protecting them it's just
like fences and borders they all have
fences around their property but heaven
forbid the us has a secure border and um
it's
it we have a rule of law in this country
and the rule of law is there
the whole concept of it to protect us
joe six-pack the normal american out
there and yet they certainly don't abide
by the rule of law they make up their
own rules it's just like their rules for
insider trading so many examples i could
give
but we get the government that we vote
for and hopefully this will wake people
up especially those in deep blue states
that have asked to be sanctuary cities
finally maybe they'll start paying
attention
someone's paying attention his name is
gavin newsom out there in california he
says
that he wants the department of justice
to go after the governors of texas and
florida and charge them with kidnapping
he wants to indict these governors on
kidnapping charges for sending these
illegal aliens on
bus rides and air flights to these
idyllic vacation spots
oh well that's par for the course newsom
there near hollywood he's such an actor
and he has to dramatize something like
that so that we'll talk about him
the guy's goofy um and i feel sorry for
the good people who live in california
and i speak to so many of them friends
of mine there who can't believe what
gavin gets away with that's that's kind
of um
it's typical of him to say such a thing
but uh wow that kind of takes the cake
how goofy that one is yeah i mean he
doesn't say word about the cartels for
all the human smuggling and kidnapping
and drug dealing but it's the it's the
governors
jesse the fentanyl the problem that we
have coming across the border and it's
not just the illegal aliens that
is
this massive humanitarian crisis is
being created by the left inviting
illegals in somebody has to take care of
them right but it's not just the people
it's what they're bringing over fentanyl
and that's killing
more people in a certain demographic or
young people than any other cause of
death all the problems coming over the
border
it's on biden's shoulders and i call on
congress to stop this binding agenda
that allows part of the fundamental
transformation of america allows the
open borders that's incentivizing people
to come on over and now yeah they're
wanting about the 50 that
yeah flew in or wrote in on air
conditioned buses and um yeah they they
can't handle that so it's
rules for the rest of us as peons while
the elites they get to skate all right
there's a great ice cream parlors in
edgar town i suggest all the migrants go
there
the pistachio is exquisite sarah palin
thank you so much for joining us
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else